you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme sri lanka is facing
possibly its biggest
environmental disaster as a ship
carrying more than a thousand
chemical containers sinks near the
country's coast as the united nations
warns we're using an
unsustainable amount of natural
resources i'll be speaking to the head
of the un environment program
about what more can be done to protect
our planet
and how discarded fishing nets are
making wales
smaller
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those developing the solutions
and coming up find out how david beckham
is helping make
ben lorries more environmentally
friendly
but we start today with what could be
the worst environmental disaster in sri
lanka's history
a fire damaged cargo ship carrying tons
of chemicals
has sunk off the country's coast
spilling chemicals
oil and microplastics and threatening
the country's pristine beaches
waters and marine life well the envy
express pearl
left the hazir report in india on the
15th of may
and was heading to singapore on the 20th
of may it was waiting to enter the port
in sri lanka's capital
colombo for a scheduled stop when a fire
broke out on the vessel
authorities were towing the ship into
deep water when it began
sinking yesterday a day after the blaze
was
extinguished well it was carrying 1486
containers including 25 tons of nitric
acid and other chemicals and cosmetics
now most of the vessels cargo was
destroyed in the fire polluting
surrounding waters
as well as a long stretch of the
country's beaches
but authorities are now worried the oil
on board
could be an even bigger problem as
siobhan robbins reports
off the coast of sri lanka the navy is
on high alert
a potential oil spill the latest
environmental threat
posed by this sinking ship
in the last fortnight the vessel laden
with chemicals
has already been hit by an explosion and
fire
sending smoke belching into the
atmosphere
and washing masses of plastic pellets
into the sea
potentially three billion plastic
pellets have been released to the
environment
so it is one of the worst environmental
if impact
already now if there was an oil spill
and some of the containers leak we're
going to actually have a bigger disaster
this is what the pellets have already
done to some of the country's beaches
fishing has been temporarily banned in
the nearby area
for some wildlife the pollution has been
deadly it is really sad to see
turtles being died on the shore
and the fishes dead fishes and
the marine lives come to the shore we
can see so many
dead bodies on the beast the plastic
pollution caused here
is expected to impact the whole of the
northern indian ocean
and the threat of an oil spill still
looms
the next few hours could prove vital in
preventing an
even bigger ecological disaster
siobhan robbins sky news well joining me
now from colombo
is melisha gunawardana advocacy
coordinator at the pearl protectors
a volunteer-based organization
protecting the marine environment
of sri lanka welcome to you just how big
an environmental disaster do you think
this is for sri lanka
um currently we have been warned of a
possible oil spill
because the ship has started to sink but
we are already looking at a pellet spill
that started
just six weeks ago six days ago and
um with an oil spill also coming it will
just add on to the worst ecological
disaster
that we've seen in our lifetime with the
ongoing nerve pollution
on our on our beaches that's just
spreading on even to the southern
coast area of sri lanka well yes because
the ship was carrying nitric
acid as well as chemicals and cosmetics
and as you say
now the fear that there'll be an oil
spill as well
what are you most concerned about what
could do the most damage
um it could be most damaging to our
marine wildlife because
our waters are abundant with marine
wildlife
we have five out of the seven species of
sea turtles
coming into the beaches of sri lanka to
nest and we have
whales that never really migrate out of
our waters and we have dolphins
and we have really sensitive coastal
ecosystems and marine ecosystems that
will
really be impacted by this because once
the oil does leak it'll leave an oil
slick
on the water and we know that marine
mammals like sea turtles they
surface to breathe and so they're likely
to breathe in these toxins
and will really have a very damaging
impact on their health
and if the oil does go into the water
column then the fish will also be
impacted
militia good and thanks very much indeed
in today's other climate news peatlands
are being destroyed to make way for palm
oil plantations in indonesia
that's according to the group human
rights watch who've criticized the
country's government
for not doing more to stop the expansion
of the crop
peatland store an estimated 80 billion
tons of carbon
but once damaged carbon dioxide is
released back into the atmosphere
causing an
increase in greenhouse gas emissions
now when you think of bin lorries you
probably wouldn't assume that david
beckham is involved
but the former footballer has taken a 10
stake in lunas
a vehicle electrification company they
convert classic cars into electric ones
and have announced they'll start up
cycling and converting
heavy industrial vehicles such as refuse
trucks and
fire engines they say converting
vehicles to run on electricity
is cheaper and more sustainable than
scrapping them and buying new ones
and a species of whale is shrinking
according to a study published by
current biology north atlantic right
whales are a meter
shorter than they were 30 years ago
because of the stresses of being
entangled in fishing nets
it means that they're less likely to be
able to reproduce and are more likely to
die from becoming caught in fishing gear
the world needs to re-wild an area the
size of
china with the level of ambition seen in
the space race
that's the recommendation from the
united nations environment programme
which has launched a decade of ecosystem
restoration it's calling for action to
restore land on a scale
never seen before saying that existing
conservation efforts are insufficient
to prevent widespread biodiversity loss
and ecosystem collapse
now they found that degradation the
deterioration of the environment
through depletion of natural resources
is affecting an estimated
3.2 billion people that's 40 percent
of the world's population one-third of
the world's
farmland is now degraded and around
66 of ocean ecosystems are damaged
degraded or modified but
115 governments have committed to
restoring around
1 billion hectares of land by 2030.
forests and landscapes can be restored
by planting
seeds where natural regeneration isn't
happening
and agroforestry can be used to grow
both trees and crops
increasing biodiversity habitats and
storing carbon
biodiversity loss is already costing the
global economy
ten percent of its output each year but
the report found
that every one dollar invested in
restoration
creates up to thirty dollars in economic
benefits
well let's bring in then the executive
director of the un environment program
inga anderson and
you're calling on the world to rewild
and restore an
area the size of china that's a huge ask
so why do you think it's so important
well as you rightly said and you
described some of the figures from the
report
the trajectory that we are on is simply
not sustainable
and we are assuming that the terrestrial
and marine
life is limitless but it is not is it
and so
if we are degrading polluting
and exhausting and losing fertility of
our soils
and if we're emptying our seas that
clearly is not
a a good solution for the future so
we have no option but to insist on
restoration
and at this point this is very very
clear that this is what we now
must do um at this point what we are
calling for
is this decade we have these 115
countries that have signed up
uh to ensure that we have ecosystem
restoration on this one billion
hectare and and it is entirely possible
we know
for example that if if we leave nature
just let it rest
it will regenerate we know it from our
gardens for our farms etc
now what we understand also of course is
that
when we use shade agriculture when we
work with agroforestry
not only is it good for our crops but it
is also
very very good for soil fertility then
we need to use less chemicals and then
we'll have less runoff in our
groundwater and into our oceans
so there's so many benefits and of
course it's not only good for
biodiversity it's not only good for
climate it's also good for property
reduction obviously
and so at this point we are trying to
mobilize a global movement
for restoration anderson thanks very
much indeed
my pleasure bangladesh is one of the
countries
most at risk from climate change but
nearly all of its energy
currently comes from fossil fuels to
move towards more renewable sources they
say they need
help from developed countries including
more money
climate finance is going to be a big
topic at cop
26 which the uk is hosting in november
the summit's president alex sharma is
visiting countries including bangladesh
to discuss the issue
before the official event well our
correspondent katherine vitotse is in
dhaka for us now and katharina
tell us more about why alok sharma is
there and what he said to you today
well alex sharma is in bangladesh for a
two-day visit it's part of a wider tour
of some of this region's most climate
vulnerable countries and his message has
been broadly the same
to everywhere he's visited he's been
urging countries to stick
to emissions targets as well as climate
change pledges and a big one of those is
of course with regards to fossil fuels
mr sharma has says that he sees it as a
personal priority for him
to end coal power but of course that
isn't easy in a country like bangladesh
which remains
overwhelmingly dependent on fossil fuels
for their energy and now because of
covid quarantine protocols we spoke to
mr sharma over
zoom here is what he said
in the case of bangladesh i've raised
this issue with ministers here
and i've been pleased to hear that they
are already looking at reducing the
number of
new power plants that they have in the
pipeline
but of course the way to ensure that
we can sign coal to history is to also
support countries like bangladesh
to make that clean energy transition
well mr sharma talked there about
transition to renewable energies and
that isn't an easy transition and it's
not a cheap one either
it will cost billions of dollars and g7
countries are yet to meet a pledge that
they made eleven years ago to be
providing a hundred billion dollars
worth of financing
per year to some of the world's most
vulnerable countries
in order to finance that transition and
for leaders here
that is still a real point of contention
they say that the world's biggest
carbon polluters need to be paying and
giving more money to those countries
that are still most at risk
well that's everything from us for today
tomorrow how sailors in the ocean
race are helping to tackle climate
change as they compete
that's at the same time tomorrow here on
sky news see you then